fou rire l'amérique tu sais pourquoi
n'était pas laval éric mallet qu'est ce
qui s'est passé exactement dit nous
n'avons pas toutes très simplement en
fait j'ai fait j'ai eu une infection
virale doublée d'une hernie discale
quand même donc les deux ensembles ont
fait que j'ai été un peu obligé d'aller
un petit peu à l'hôpital et puis ensuite
à la mise aux normes ont été très
inquiet pompe c'est vrai que voilà vous
étiez donc voté de ma très bien ça
devait passer combien de temps de reclus
dans un mois et demi en 1900 bouger donc
de votre jeu c'est un match ira tout cas
là ça va mieux vous arrivez à gueugnon
pas où ça va ça va vous nous avez
vraiment manquer vous regarder à la télé
tous les soirs et voyeuse envoyé des
petits mots et puis voilà je sais que
c'est serré que vous avez vécu des
moments difficiles
et sachez qu'en tout cas nous vous nous
avez manqué aussi on a vécu des moments
difficiles sont maintenant et puis voilà
vraiment tout cela autour de la table
benjamin mam a envoyé des messages tous
les jours qu'un film il vaut peut-être
sur marie